hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 20 video whole bunch
of stuff they're setting up I think
they're seating some stuff for season 5
too so I'll try to talk about that but
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet surprising number
of comic book Easter eggs but I'm
wondering if they're setting up the
question for next season because if I
haven't talked about it in a video
before they announced like a big villain
they're casting for season 5 they give a
fake name but they gave a description
that could end up being the big sage
question character it just seems like
they've been referencing Hub City on all
the different shows multiple times so it
feels like they're just setting
something up there but arrow has
mentioned a whole bunch of other
fictional cities from the DC Universe
like blood Haven opal City so it could
just be coincidence but here we go beau
the top 5 WTF and I'll explain Easter
eggs as we go along I know there were
some questions about what's going on
with will at the end of the episode
that's all part of the Easter eggs
there's some comic book stuff going on
with that storyline but it's a little
bit different from the way it happened
in the comics so number five WTF damian
darhk-- comes roaring back with a
vengeance just kills off half of the
hive that he's been working with anybody
else got a problem with that makes a
joke about Merlin's hand
thank you very much one of the things
that neal mcdonough the guy that's
playing damian darhk-- does really well
is really snappy funny dialogue like
this that normally like if you were to
give it to a lesser actor it would just
sound so ham-fisted but he pulls it off
so well obviously I think we all expect
Oliver to defeat him in the finale
especially after what happened in this
week's episode and I don't know that
they would try to kill him off in a
permanent way usually they try to leave
some backdoor explainer in case they
want to bring him back in the future
Deathstroke is the best example of that
there's always the conversation about
unkillable villains because it's like
how do you give your hero a really
definitive win without being able to
take the villain down permanently well
if you're a comic book lover you
probably just learn to accept that
things come back all the time different
writers come on we've had the Lazarus
Pit a lot of it has to do with
contractual stuff behind the scenes and
the internal logic of the show so
there's a lot of hand waving and logic
gaps that you just hope it all works out
at the end it's the same deal on the
flash they have a really good set up a
really good pitch but the hard part is
sticking the landing at the end of the
season like paying off the big thing
that you were setting up but number four
WTF we finally catch up with Lyla she's
on a moving transport safehouse which I
thought was a pretty
cool reveal and reference belly burger
again we haven't seen belly burger in a
while on the show the first couple
seasons especially the first season of
the flash every chance they got there
was belly burger like they even had the
belly burger set in arrow season one
which I think they turned into the set
that they use for Oliver's office but I
don't know they changed the sets every
once in a while but number three WTF
speaking of the office Alex takes the on
vacation which seems kind of weird to do
in there in lockdown mode but logic
whatever she wakes up totally sounds
like she's been roofied and starts to
pick up that she's inside The Truman
Show so later in the episode like the
big reveal is is that she's in a secret
city underneath starch city that they're
just gonna use to house all the people
that they want to survive this big
nuclear holocaust that they're gonna
pull off they might wind up calling this
City Monument point because Monument
point in the comics Marc Guggenheim the
showrunner for arrow wrote this big
Justice Society arc it was pre
flashpoint I think when you know DC
rebooted their universe they've done it
a couple times since then
in Monument Point is the big city where
the Justice Society battles the villain
it ends up getting destroyed but Jay
Garrick later becomes the mayor they
help rebuild it it turns into this
wonderful place again so there is a
Genesis of sorts the title of this
episode is Genesis so the arc might wind
up being Monument point from the city
you know metaphorically obviously
they're changing the comic book
storyline quite a bit it is one of the
few stories in the DC universe where a
giant city gets destroyed then rebuilt
bigger and better than ever
we still don't know how alex is involved
only that he's been taking those crazy
roofie pills that Ruthie Adams is
beginning of damien darhk's wife sure
why don't you take these mystery pills
they're vitamins they'll totally make
you feel better this is so funny it's
almost like invasion of the Body
Snatchers I'm still expecting some kind
of Alex reveal either is in on it or
he's important for some other reason
we've never heard his last name we only
know his name is Alex I gave my number
two to Oliver learning how to channel
dark magic one of the things that I'd
like about this is they're finally
getting to the point where Oliver is
learning about magic they should have
done it a long time ago and it's all
making sense now he had to see how
things went bad with the idol in the
past to know how to try and avoid that
landmine in the future so Oliver has to
find a way to not be sad Affleck he is
effectively going to have magical powers
but the real magic in this episode was
Diggle this was really more
diggle's episode than it was all of our
episode even though the Oliver stuff is
a really big plot point so you look at
all the storylines and you think about
what's going on with Oliver then you
think about how Diggle is dealing with
his darkness like he is slowly slipping
into a darker place as Oliver's going to
a lighter place the title of the finale
is schism so I'll let you think about
that but we got some of the best Diggle
scenes from any season of the show in
this my new favorite serious Diggle
scene was with Lyla at the end of the
episode where he was explaining how he
killed Andi but on the flip side of that
I do have to say that Andi was just way
too over-the-top like you could
definitely tell that they were trying to
make him seem irredeemable is is if the
writer of the episode wanted to make it
seem like Diggle was justified in
killing him I felt like it would have
been better if it was more ambiguous but
the way the actor played it especially
that final scene made it seem like he
was actually taking crazy pills like
damian darhk-- had ordered him to get
Diggle to kill him like make your
brother kill you that's the only way his
performance in that scene makes sense to
me but you guys can let me know like
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and do you think all this hub
city stuff is leading to the question
but just to explain the Nexus stuff so
they said there is a magical Nexus
inside Star City which surprise surprise
is probably somewhere close to that
secret city there's a nexus on Lian Yu
so they're just these magical places
that exist outside of our dimension
they haven't fully explained it yet but
as you probably guessed we will visit
the Nexus in Star City it will probably
be involved in the big final battle
there are a couple other Easter eggs
that I haven't mentioned yet the furn
came back usually the fern is mentioned
at least once per season if you remember
there was a firm between seasons when
Oliver was living in the old arrow cave
it's a very Oliver Felicity specific
Easter egg but it totally loved the John
Constantine shout out there keeping him
in the universe even if he is physically
not able to visit the universe because
he's off doing some other TV show when
the actor can come back I think he'll
come back so hopefully he'll come back
next season I'd love to see my legends
of tomorrow too
but they haven't really said anything
about the plot of that next year there
was also an anarchy name-drop I know
he's coming back again before the end of
the season but I don't know which
episode it might be Monument Point which
is next week's episode and I think the
Felicity's father is also coming back
the calculator is coming back for next
week's episode and you may have
recognized Felicity's take from
- when she took down Ravager weapon of
choice the arrow mobile if you guys
haven't seen it yet you can click here
to learn all about Avengers infinity war
they're gonna be changing the title so I
just listed my top 10 favorites I'm also
doing a Captain America Civil War
giveaway and you can click here for last
night's episode of the flash thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight